personne à normale sup en liberté
seraient donc dans l'illégalité
les personnes normales sont dangereuses
les laisser en liberté est impossible
[Musique]
louis quelqu'un aurait pu te voir tu
connais la punition si tu en feras des
règles tu ouvert la porte
on aurait pu se faire tuer on doit
rester caché jusqu'à quand on joue plus
il est sorti ce nom tu dois jamais menti
tu mens pages toujours mon papa aussi ça
une molette ya déjà eu les yeux qui
saignent
les soutiens arrivent à faire des choses
que les autres ne peuvent pas faire du
débat spécial
leur pouvoir s'intensifie génération
après génération
leurs enfants sont définies comme étant
lourdes et armes de destruction massive
on n'arrivera jamais à sortir d'ici
pinault
cacher ça ne sert à rien
je vais sortir avec la fille
je suis prêt
[Musique]
le cacher
je suis vraiment désolé c'est vrai que
des spéciales
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]